we are gonna do a bunch of octane tests
today one of which we're gonna I have
mirage you can apparently send the
bamboozles on to the launch pad wanna
bamboozle all right get the big boot
what hey I did that wrong do it I don't
know
didn't not work oh there what where did
it go
it looked like I went somewhere it
looked like it but then it also
disappeared now he just straight up oh
hey so when shooting me think you can
bamboozle off of the thingy you should
try it again it's kind of in a weird
spot you get throw it on top of the bone
yeah maybe the bones are just buggy you
know buggy bones
[Music]
one more time oh but it still it
disappears yeah oh wait our stars not
gonna work I just saw my shield whatever
thermite's not gonna work either never
grenade yeah I mean you would need you
would need something that's not gonna
like detonate on impact right like
that's a grenade so this probably
probably won't work oh that's
interesting you can think of that it
just says it might be something good
there it doesn't actually say what you
doing finishing oh that's silly goose
oh it doesn't even look like you
shooting at it hell yeah that was sick
then you go into the smoke
[Music]
this would be hilarious nice all right
cool great what you did yes I'd bust at
their party damn little Oh skills all
right
how come your portraits don't show up
cuz we don't deserve it
so Mirage decoys if you maybe get it
right it looks like it flies like but it
disappears like almost right away
Bangalore's smoke gas canister can be
ricocheted off your needs can be
ricocheted off neurons can be not the
arc sir yeah just Grenada and thermal
there my thermite and grenade plastic
straps can be bounced yeah the lifeline
package doesn't balance it breaks it
that was cool so the only other thing we
didn't try with your altars you know I'd
never work
yeah I bet that word I bet I bet caustic
gas canister works - oh you mean his old
notes gasping yeah for sure this is
gamespot live we're live Monday to
Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
you should subscribe join tuna tune in
for you know hopeful championship days
like today just one today but that's
okay thank you all for watching until
next time stay tuned for an awesome
guide that's right you're gonna do that
I go fast
all right later dudes
[Music]